so you're paying 650 a month and how
much rent do you get in April we made to
an Afghan profit off that one damn so
what was your first deal and how did it
come about funnily enough from your
Instagram story you open 800 a month and
then you just registered it for six
grand for a week you haven't got a
business unless it's systemized you've
got a job you thought you had a
construction company now you don't
negotiated seven thousand Pounds off the
asking price with refurbs 18 Grand and
they should refinance for 145. how much
is your property company on average
making a month between doing thirteen
thousand a month up until May which we
did 27 000. that's enough to buy a house
Kenny and Carl thanks so much for coming
down to my house I wanted to interview
you because you are a father and son Duo
what you've done over the last year in
property how you've scaled up Forward
Thinking nuts of your property business
is absolutely admirable and I thought
I'd pick your brain on what you've done
what's working what's not working and uh
but firstly congratulations on all your
successive property thank you cheers how
did this all start then what happened I
know you've got a construction company
but so Kenny Source about their a resin
business doing resin floors which wasn't
going very well and he was a bit down in
the dumps so I said right we need to do
something together have a look at this
guy being Samuel Leeds when you've had a
look come back to me and see what you
want to do so he came back to me and
said let's book that one pound session
and then from there we came down to uh
Heathrow and when you showed your son
Kenny and you're like you need to go to
the property investor crash course were
you thinking for yourself as well that
you wanted to do that absolutely and
okay so you were like I need to get into
problem date well I wanted to do this
together and I wanted to be a bill
business built from scratch that he put
loads of inputs in so he wasn't a silver
spoon boy he was coming out and he was
he was making his own money
um why do you think so many people in
the construction business
have this sort of old school because I
get a lot of people that you know even
comments people say I've been in the
construction business for years oh rent
to rents it's all nonsense there's this
sort of like old school mentality I
think within the construction business
and where do you think that comes from I
think it's probably because you end up
repairing so many trashed properties but
you don't see the good ones so you get
it in your mind that they're all like
that yeah and that's it but they're not
it's it's a you know there's millions of
them out there we only remember the
horror stories yeah so you came down
then so you've got your construction
business and you had your struggling
flooring business that you wanted to
Jack in how did you feel at that point
Canada what was all in like regardless
of of whether I thought you know the
crash course is any good property was I
was gonna do that yeah we were going to
do that did you know at the time what
your strategy was going to be or were
you still figuring that out
um we had an inkling towards Dale sawson
that was sort of what we wanted to do
obviously since then we've gone through
the mill and the trials and tribulations
have been an academy member and and what
different strategies there are and all
these different pots and we've come out
at the back end where we are so and what
are you doing now then what's your main
focus where's most of the money coming
from now deal selling but also rent to
rent so what was your first deal and how
did it come about uh so funny enough
from your story your Instagram story a
guy messaged me and said look I was
scrolling through 36 different stories
and for some reason I just stopped on
yours so he reached out to me and said
I'm looking for a bit alert
so I found him on but I said it needs 8
000 pounds worth of refurb to get it to
the point that you want it in terms of
the rent so it's like fine as we were
going along before we got to any
important stage so we're just on the rip
out and whatever I said to him why don't
we
rent this off you as a rent to rent
we'll give you what you want for it so
you're making your profit we'll increase
it by 3.5 each year so we stay in line
with inflation whatever
and then we will use it as a service
accommodation for contractors
and he was like Bingo let's do it so
hold on this is crazy so this was the
deal selling masterclass no you just you
just re-shared something I'd put and
tagged you in okay I stopped on it for
some reason and I'm quite a big believer
I believe about the universe and Law of
Attraction stuff like that so I I think
it could be something to do with that I
don't know so we saw your potential deal
and what was it was it like a buy to let
the deal was just a standard bite to let
so he wanted a buy to let it was our
first investor on board yeah Kenny
brought him on we found the deal and
then we we said we'll take the deal off
you so you buy it refer a bit and then
we'll rent it back off you for three
years okay so it's a double deal yeah
yeah yeah so you're you're getting a fee
but then he's getting a guaranteed rent
which means you're getting a rent to
rent that's right yeah okay but what we
did is then we could decide what we
wanted to do on the build and work to
make it more appealing as a rent to rent
but the thing is with property is the
pie is big enough for everyone to get
paid you know and you can get paid to
deal saucer he can get paid as a as a
passive investor the pie is big enough
so how much did he pay you as a sources
fee uh 2000 for the sauce and fee 1200
for the project management and then we
actually added 35 000 pounds of faculty
in three weeks which is 27 000 net and
how much rent are you paying him 650. so
you're paying 650 a month and how much
rent do you get
in April we made to an Afghan profit off
that one damn so the big question is
then a lot of people say is why doesn't
he just rent it out himself a service
combination and this comes up all the
time because whenever you're doing a
rental around if you're renting a
property then you're renting out a
service accommodation everyone says why
doesn't the landlord Do It
um what was your answer be to that bit
weary of chance in it yeah yeah that's
all I think don't you don't know if they
could quite cope with their the
management system yeah it's time
consuming isn't it time consuming yeah
and also I guess as well in a similar
way it's you could say that about
anything couldn't you like the hotel
business when Premier Inn rent a
building and then run it as a Premier
Inn and make a fortune you can say well
why doesn't just the the owner run it as
a hotel well they don't know how they
don't know the systems the procedures
the process you've got to have to desire
yeah without the desire you're not going
to do it if you've got the desire to do
it because you've got to find cleaners
key boxes working on online travel
agencies and avivo channel managers
synchronizing calendars and all these
monitors yeah noise monitor
you don't know how to do it I mean you
know you've been trained you've got the
business in a box you've got all the
processes you've got community mentors
and you've made a success of it but most
people it's just too daunting isn't it
too daunting yeah and we've learned the
hard way through the noise monitors as
well we'll go on tell me we've got an
apartment that has one above and it's
actually above a funeral directors so
that means super quiet in the day super
quiet at night for the for the guys
upstairs and I got a call at like 2 A.M
saying the downstairs doing this and
that the shouting screaming and I was
just like
and with the landlord I'd actually agree
that we would put a sound monitor in but
I forgot to do it
that was my mess up so I then had to you
know grovel a little bit so I'm really
sorry this and that
but the guests were saying we never did
anything so obviously now I've got to be
like well I can't charge them because he
said they haven't done anything I've got
no noise monsters to prove it and the
ring doorbell wasn't charged
so that's something
we'll put it right yeah yeah but that
that actual apartment is in a place
where the open is going to be the gulf
open
and we've we've left that out for the
golf open for one week cool six grand
six grand for a week for a week and how
much rent are you paying to the landlord
800 800. so you're paying 800 pound a
month and then you just receive the six
grand for a week two weeks yeah
that is nuts and it turns its whales
anyway without that but that's just like
Brucey bonus isn't it and you've got a
br going on at the moment talk to me a
bit about that so that is literally like
four minutes away from Liverpool tunnel
and it's going to be a service
accommodation I sourced it for them we
we negotiated seven thousand Pounds off
the asking price which is nice uh the
refurbs 18 Grand and they should
refinance for 145. how do you juggle
then doing like deal sourcing red I mean
you've got what barnstone property
sourcing and then you've got Boston
construction you're doing you rent to
rent service accommodation how do you
kind of find the time and balance all of
that and also working together as well
how do you split the responsibilities up
and and work together yeah so building
companies now more systemized put some
Foreman in place yeah they're running
the jobs so I'm less on site so I've got
more time to spend with Kenny talking
about business plans and where we're
going this week and we'll have a project
for the month ahead Kenny will do the
social media died in his time and in his
work hours and he'll do the viewings but
we're also just now training up another
guy to deal source as well so he's going
to do the deal sourcing for us while
we're bringing the the investors on
board how much is your property company
on average making a month in profit
after all your costs so we didn't make
any money up until January so we had
that long slug I've got you know a few
months where we didn't make any money
but since then it's been doing 13 000 a
month up until May which we did 27 000
from mid-may to June wow
what makes you so successful just seemed
like a normal father and son doing you
think that how are you making so much
maybe 27 Grand in that amount of time
and isn't his nuts I actually think
you've just said it I think the fact
that we are just normal blokes
what we're going to do we came away
we've took what we wanted from the
course
took the golden nuggets and worked away
at them and made them work you've got to
know that the nuggets and where they are
and which ones to pull out yeah what
were some of the big like aha moments
for you where some of the things that
you learned and you're like oh my gosh
this is going to be a game changer
systemization right talk to me about
that so systemization I think it was
Tony said it on stage and he said you
haven't got a business unless it's
systemized you've got a job
yeah and I sat there and it was when
Bing I've got a job you thought you were
a construction company now you don't you
own your own job had a full-time own job
that's all it went through in my mind
for a couple of months how do we change
this what do we do and completely
changed my mindset
to to bring me to where I am now and
involve this business with Kelly how did
you call how did you systemize the
construction because it's not easy I
mean I know in the in in the building
game everybody wants you trying to get
employees and staff it's very difficult
in the building business
how have you managed to do that well
we've got a great team of lads we really
have so one of the guys pulled him to
the side straight away as soon as I got
back and said do you want more
responsibility
obviously with more money and you run
the jobs for me so I don't have to turn
up on the site which then gives us more
time for deal sourcing and essays so you
pay me a little bit more money but now
you've got your time back and it's not
as chaotic because I'm not trying to do
everything what would you say though
because I have so many builders that say
to me Samuel you don't understand I
can't Outsource this that stuff I can't
systemize it because all my clients just
want me how did you deal with that it's
not true it's in your own head but I I
agree it is it's their ego they think oh
they only want me because I'm so
wonderful I can't let go yeah you don't
cut that like that do you think really
they just control freaks yeah as long as
the end product is right and the thing
is the client might have a slight
preference like we've got a builder that
we use who project manages everything
right on our projects around here and I
really like him his name's Andy really
like Andy trust him he's a brilliant
Builder and he manages the team well if
Andy turned around to me one day and
just said oh Pete's gonna now be doing
my job I might be a bit like oh unsure
but Andy needs to educate me and show me
and prove that Pete's good and if Pete
comes along and actually Wows me and
there's a good okay so really it's about
just replacing yourself and setting the
expectations right with your customers
yeah so like customers they're not
employing me they're employing our
company right and we're overseeing it
that all the guys that work for the
company work under our umbrella so you
just need to make sure the job gets done
well and they all go through a training
Matrix as well anyway on top of all that
yeah so you have to train them well so
remember training and then we've got
them going through all their asbestos
awareness working from height SM STS so
we've got a proper system in place so
we're making sure that you know everyone
knows what they're doing completely
we're not just going to start smashing
holes in a our Tech ceiling which is
full of asbestos how does it feel um
Carl to have systemized your building
business
absolutely amazing yeah I feel like got
my life back that's awesome yeah
congrats on that yeah thanks that's a
huge achievement yeah how many hours do
you have to spend a week now on your
construction business probably still
putting two days in yeah yeah and what
we're doing before
uh nine nine days
[Laughter]
full time
interesting that's huge and with with
yourself as well Kenny you're kind of
the front guy on social media I see you
doing the post getting the investors and
things like that how is it working
together like as like a Duo family
business yeah it's easy because there's
no one I trust more than him
so you know and actually you know it's
we're two males as well so sometimes we
do Clash heads naturally but it always
ends in a nice open discourse okay
what's the best resolve we'll agree on
it move forward that's done then there's
no you know lumps in the carpet like it
all gets ironed out straight away and
that's the same with me my brother we're
business partners and we have a rule
which is what's best for the business
yes because if you're always saying
what's best for me or you're trying to
be selfish or it's actually what's best
for the business business comes first
yes and and everything has to be fair
and if there's problems then you just
address it you have to quickly resolve
things communication is important do you
guys have like an organizational
structure what you have who's doing what
who's responsible for what yeah so so
pretty much I will get the business and
bring it in once I've got the client on
the hawk site and we have a zoom call
I'll bring dad in we'll do Zoom calls
together because you know I want people
to feel
he's a credible source of information
for building I'll handle the property
source and stuff
and we come together like that yeah and
that's how it works what are you most
excited about with the construction
business rent to rent and building your
own portfolio of brrs like which is the
most exciting so I think going to our
own portfolio when I say our own which
we own which we've done from scratch
it's not I'm not putting the money in
Kenny and I have worked I brought that
in with that turnover we've just told
you and we're going to buy our first
property this year and then we're going
to leverage that property and keep going
do the works refinance it yeah but we'll
probably put sweat money into that one
and do a lot of the building work to
make it more
fruitful so that 27 Grand was that
overused for month period we saw like
six weeks and how much of that was
profit that's profit that's enough to
buy a house but then we've also agreed
on rents events and I was like oh we've
got to furnish them and it comes down
the pot as you know and also that 27
Grand is not guaranteed next month you
know like yeah we're not taking 27 Grand
wage or anything like that we're
reinvested back in the business yes of
course going back in yeah yeah yeah of
course and that's the way it should be
it's gonna work for us and in 10 years
it'll be working a lot better go on my
27 Grand go on holiday and have a great
time buy a car but actually you're
wanting to put that into something
that's going to give you a passive
income which is hopefully the rent to
rents but what we want to move into is
doing JV developments because we build
new build houses anyway so why can't we
leverage that scale bring other people
in on the finance side like we were
literally looking at a deal right now
aren't we yeah I've got going to look at
one on Monday which is uh
plus a land in an area where they sell
for about 1.6 million per year which is
which is which is high yeah and for the
area well it sounds high for livable
yeah we're looking it's got planning
permission already but the garden next
door has also got another house next
door is
really needs knocking down but that's
going to come as the package so there'll
be two plots right so it could be a four
or five million pound deal how are you
finding these deals like even the rent
to rent and and the bras and the
development deals are you find them
through estate agents are you finding
them off Market networking events yeah
both both really
um because we sell houses for estate
agents naturally they're going to come
to us straight away because they don't
have to Market it then if they can sell
their deal for them also family friends
you know people see what we're doing on
Facebook Instagram whatever and then
networking events like your courses what
about the investors how are you finding
these investors where are they coming
from where the mouth you explain
well so safely come through Instagram
which some of them do or and the academy
or whatever then I'll actually put them
in touch with previous investors and say
speak to them ask them what you thought
of me they won't hold anything back and
then all of a sudden that you know they
call me back and say yeah let's do it so
you're using like referrals or
recommendations for your inquiries yes
and where would you say most of the
focuses then on the on the property
business if you had to sort of source in
restaurants developments so awesome but
the great thing about sourcing is if
you're sourcing deals
if you're finding something you can keep
it you can partner you can sell it the
biggest problem people have in this
business I think is being able to sort
good deals because everyone thinks oh I
haven't got the money oh I haven't got
any investors I haven't well you ain't
even got the deals I could give you 150
Grand right now and you wouldn't have
the first clue what to do with it so the
real trick of the game is being able to
find the deals know what a good deal is
know how to Crunch the numbers know
where to look how to spot the
opportunities I think that's the biggest
key so what tips would you have from
your experience both in construction but
also in in the business of property
about knowing what to look for in a good
deal how do you know if a deal is a good
deal or not I think you've got to be
realistic about your construction costs
like do not try and inflate those
numbers to make it work yeah if it
doesn't work it doesn't work move on or
inflating the end value because one
freaky house sold for 300 Grand but
realistically they're all selling for
260. and that's tough isn't it yeah it's
tough search isn't it do your research
get your data right and also you've got
to add in contingency and stuff haven't
you as well with any with any job you've
got to make sure your numbers are really
right yeah so we always knock off like
10 for our GDB and refurb you've got you
build a cost and then you've got your 15
profits five percent contingency and
then even that people Miss on that and
it's like
yeah right you know what I mean yeah
have you um agreed any purchase lease
options yet close weren't we close we've
we've had talks and we've been in the
situation where they may have gone but
um we've done the figures and walked
away in the end you keep saying this
it's so important I think
being prepared to walk away is so
important because I've seen a lot of
people especially inexperienced people
that aren't really trained or educated
they're quite emotional and they'll get
emotionally attached to a deal and then
they'll fudge the figures to make it
work because really their heart's saying
yes but the biggest tip is fill your
pipeline if you've got 20 deals on I bet
you right now I bet you guys have got at
least 10 different potential deals on
the table right now absolutely yeah and
that way oh well that one doesn't work
if you've only got one in your pipeline
you're desperate for it to work because
if it doesn't work then you've got
nothing yes correct you're trying to set
out you want to get going yeah you need
that deal you'll do anything for it to
work but you can't be a motivated
investor you have to be a smart investor
dealing with motivated sellers well we
do an exercise called I think I know so
we'll write on the Whiteboard and we'll
get all the I thinks about it and we'll
just Chuck them in the bin and just put
I knows on the board and then we'll make
a decision right and we do that all the
time don't we pretty much every day but
you know I mean deal sources to sell
with I think they'll say oh I think that
they're going to be bringing in a new
train station and we think that the
market value will go up over the next
three years you don't know that nonsense
talk a bit about as well the difference
between because this is a mad one
important for deal sources the
difference between
the asking price and the true current
market value it's very difficult at the
moment because there's limited
properties on the market so to actually
pull a below market value is difficult
yeah I always do a square metage so I
want to know how much you're paying per
square meter in that area on average
this year yeah look at the house
comprised if it's way over inflated but
if it's Justified because it's really
nice inside this is night extension then
you can be like right okay that's
Justified but if it isn't then you know
hang on a second that's not the current
market value yeah it should be this yeah
because one of the things that novices
do is they'll be a property on the
market for 150. and then they'll
negotiate to buy it for 130. oh I've got
20 grand below market value but actually
when you look at it and you look at the
comparable prices it's only worth 130.
so actually this 20 grand below market
value is 20 grand below asking price but
asking price it's irrelevant they could
be asking a million pounds but at the
same time they can be the other the
other way around what I've seen
investors or novices they're looking at
property for 150 Grand
and actually it's on the market for 150
but the sellers motivated and really
it's worth 165 but it's on cheap but
then they'll put in a cheeky off of one
two five and it's like no it's already
cheap like what are you doing so being
able to calculate that figure I think
he's really important what have been
some of the biggest learning points for
you then Kenny and doing what you've
been doing with getting investors and
selling deals well I've been some of the
biggest uh learning points probably to
be a bit more thick skin to be honest
naturally I'm quite a sensitive
emotional person so when you get that no
first deal will be sold and got the
money in the bank for was a brr in
Liverpool and
the compiler we used was in the road
next door but that was a different
postcode so the investor was like no I
want my money back that's not secure and
safe enough but it was a light for late
property next Road
so I sent the money back and I said to
my dad I was like oh Dad it's not
working this and that now I've come
through the trials and tribulations of
that I'm a bit like no hang on a sec I
know to put all my due builders in a
pack I'll pack sometimes are like 50
Pages deep you know for bigger deals
which a lot of people like can't read
that but if you say the information's
not there I can guarantee you it is
so take your time to read the pack see
the information that's probably the
biggest learning I have about also we've
done the job pay us not in three months
which you're greater we're done oh the
master yeah did all that work for you
that is yeah it's quite easy yeah right
because people say I'll pay you on
completion but I've already done the
work yeah exactly yeah you can pay me
now if you're not happy when you're
doing your due diligence in the survey
or whatever you've got a 14 day calling
off period what did you learn at the DLC
master class and what did you think when
you saw me live just selling deals over
and over and over again because I don't
think people quite until you've actually
experienced it when I when I tell people
come on the program bring deals and
you'll see me ringing investors selling
the deal live I don't think people quite
believe it I thought it was Ace because
the way you do it it's killer like get
it done and you've actually got to be
like that in this industry it's so
competitive and then watching you do a
lot live on stage made me realize right
I can do it I just need to be a little
bit more hard-faced about it you have to
be able to close the deal some people
just can't and in England we're very
polite so you have to be able to
actually be direct this is the deal what
are your thoughts it looks great perfect
month is 3 000 pounds how do you feel
about that that sounds reasonable great
how would you like to pay I do need to
refresh on that I've got we've the way
we do it now is purely bespoke okay but
which has good points yeah it does I
like bespoke the bad points about it I
think is that you can't push out deals
on mass it's all you know I go and look
at it we price up the refurb we do the
work yeah a lot very time consuming we
need to do some deals where we don't
include the builders work so we've come
up with a new strategy for that go on so
the new strategy is this is what we
think you can do the builders work and
project and manage it yourself yeah this
is what we think you can do at using
those and this is the fee and it's going
to be quite a large fee on top to use us
to project manage and bring that in on
if you want that security that you've
got so much paid for it then yeah
because I mean construction as you know
Kenny does work Construction Company too
but I know over the years I get a lot
more for building an extension and
refurb and a buyer left of course of
course because I can allow time for
reform and pre-length costs washrooms
toilets Etc you ain't getting that on a
vital and it depends on how much they've
had their time yeah if somebody lives
locally and they've got the time they'll
say no actually I'll bought my own
electrician my own plan on my own this
yes they were all getting each other's
way and it'll be a nightmare and I'll
have to budget manage it but it'll be a
lot cheaper which means that we can sell
more deals because because there's only
so many we can refurb with the team
we've got it's almost like saying you
know do you want it done good
cheap or fast which one yeah because you
can't have all three you can't have it
done good and cheap and fast at the
moment our clients probably are getting
that only yeah to get a cheap and fast
yeah yeah and good but you you cut
that's not sustainable you can't have
good food fast food and cheap food all
at once you've ever cheap and fast you
get it good and slow you have a good and
fast but it won't be cheap so which one
do you want and then let them choose
what's the difference Kenny between
bespoke deal sourcing and regular deal
sourcing yeah so regular deal sources
where you go find deal package it up
push out to like a list of investors
bespoke is where you onboard a client
they pay you a deposit for you to go and
actually look for them you'll have a
contract to see how many properties
You're Going To Source in an amount of
time and the criteria to work too which
is a framework to protect the saucer and
the clients you'll go and find their
property you'll take the deposit away
from the sourcing fee sure and then
charge them on whatever your terms are
for us it's sale agreed so you're
basically selling a deal to an investor
that when the deal doesn't even exist
yet yes so they're paying you a fee up
front yeah a grand let's say and then
they'll say now this is what I want this
this you'll go find it and then they'll
top up the difference the great thing
about that is you can use their proof of
funds you can use their photo ID you
know that when you find something good
it's gonna sell what did your family
think when you joined the academy and
told them that your new Venture of
property that was everyone like yeah man
sounds good or didn't think you were
crazy I wouldn't say crazy they were
interested
um Milan is like moving that's more
money is just on board with anything we
say we're gonna do it and she's yeah
she's your biggest fan yeah
she wants essays yeah that's great yeah
and my granddad is more like we're
skeptical not too sure but now he's
saying it he's like you know boys well
done yeah and I want some yeah yeah
that's great when you can bring your
family in and it's great working with
your family and it's so nice to have
family on board and supporting a lot of
people in your situation Kenny their dad
would be saying don't go to that course
whereas your day I'm saying you have to
go yeah yeah so it's a real it's a it's
a real good thing I'm blessed that I've
got the network through the academy
I've got my friends who are sharks as
well winners so every time I meet them
they're like you know don't tell me what
they're doing their business and then I
go away thinking yeah I need to match
their energy yeah and then I've got my
family as well and my dad my girlfriend
you know supporting me and it's just
who else is waiting gold what was your
experience in the academy with the
network unbelievable the training
unbelievable and you know what you're
held accountable because you've paid for
it absolutely and that's the thing
you're around other people they've all
invested they're all serious what better
place to be and what better place to
find investors as well true yeah so well
guys I'm really pleased to see you
winning in business and congrats on your
success look forward to seeing your
continued success and thank you so much
for coming down from Liverpool thanks
for having us thank you respect well
done thanks Kenny thank you Carl
[Music]
thank you